. Einen wunderschönen guten Tag, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von DPU, der Podcast mit dem Ufo, der Podcast mit dem Ufo, DPU, da verstehen wir, hallo, herzlich willkommen, hallo Florentin Will. Wieder eine gute Morgenfolge, habe ich das Gefühl, oder, wir sind wieder herbkratzig unterwegs, nicht wahr, stimmlich wieder kurz nach dem Backup. Ja, oder krank.. Kann auch sein. Langsam bahnt es sich an. Da du dich weigerst, mich vorzustellen, muss ich mich kurz selber vorstellen. Mein Name ist Stefan Michael. Stefan Tiziano! Und das Intro ist von meinem persönlichen, sehr guten Freund Simon. Vielen Dank, Simon. Simon! Ein fantastisches Intro, das uns hier wirklich die Tür aufmacht, danke.
Ja, vor allem, es hat wieder diese alten Sci-Fi-Vibes, die ich lange vermisst habe, weil das ist auch ein bisschen die Essenz, dieses Abenteuer, das UFO, was in die weite Welt hinausgeht.
Wir streben nach oben, wir wollen unentdeckte Sphären kennenlernen.
Er hat es auf dem Handy geschrieben, irgendwo in Patagonien, also das war der Kumpel, den ich besucht habe in Peru.
Ach Gott, seid ihr alle so unausstehlich, der ganze Freundeskreis. Ich war ja in Peru. Ach wirklich, ist ja fast so schön wie Patagonien. Da musst du auch mal unbedingt hin. Wir lieben Orte mit P. Aber auf der anderen Seite, nee, der ist immer noch unterwegs, ist die gleiche Reise. Also no hate, kein Reise-Hate. Moment, der ist immer noch unterwegs während der Reise, wo du zu Peru mal kurz gesagt hast, ich schau rein. Ja, wo ich ehrlich gesagt habe, hallo, mehr von Peru und am Ende lass mich in Ruhe mit Peru. Das war diese Reise, da bin ich kurz dazu gestossen, zu dem Trip. Jetzt ist er in Patagonien, jetzt auf dem Weg, aber auf einer Fähre irgendwo in Richtung Ecuador. Aber ist der sehr langsam oder ist die Welt sehr gross? Die Welt ist, glaube ich, nicht so trivial klein. Ja? Ja, ja, ich glaube, das ist schon ein Act. Na, ich glaube, aber wie viel, 88 Tagen um die Welt? Ja, aber ich glaube, da ist dein Ziel Geschwindigkeit. Ah ja, okay. Und ich glaube, Simons Ziel ist, Kulturen kennenlernen, auf Ayahuasca hängenbleiben, allen auf die Nerven gehen danach mit, wie krass lebensverändernd Ecuador war. Ich kenne Patagonien. Ich kenne Patagonien. Ich weiß, wo das ist. Das ist kein ausgedachtes Land. Oder doch, du kannst es nicht wissen, deswegen kann ich sagen. Ich weiß alles über Südamerika. Ich bin nur jedenfalls stolz, er hat das auf dem Handy geschrieben und ja, hat es mir geschickt. Ich habe mich sehr gefreut. Vielen Dank, Simon, liebe Grüße nach wo auch immer du jetzt bist. Ja, ihr könnt euch ja schon lange, ne? Also auch schon aus der alten... Ja, er ist in der Bandzeit. Aus der alten Bandzeit. Er ist in aller Stuhlfrohne ist ja Sagt, er war das Sagt. Er war Sagt, ich war Buh und Kumpel war Binky. Erst war der Gitarrist und zweiter Gitarrist und Keyboarder unserer fantastischen kleinen Musikkombination, die ja wahnsinnige Erfolge gefeiert hat. Auf jeden Fall. Das muss man sagen. Grammy war jetzt, gut, direkt nach dem Echo ... War er nominiert? Wir waren Emmy-nominiert. Emmy-nominiert. Wir waren Emmy-nominiert für unsere Dokumentation. Ja. Diese verdammte Fergie, ne? Hat die verdammte Fergie euch wieder den Emmy weggeschnappt? Ich hasse Fergie. Fergie ist unser grosser Rival. Es war immer Fergie gegen uns. Fergie first hieß es immer. Es war immer Fergie first bei den Emmys, jedes Jahr aufs Neue. Es hieß immer Fergie gegen uns, weißt du, wie bei Rush, dieser Film, ne, lauter gegen, ich weiß nicht mehr, der andere hieß, der Engländer, aber so was bei auch bei... Vergessen, genau, ja, vergessen, genau wie Binggie sagt, vergessen, aber Fergie, weil Fergie und uns sind Rangler, genau. Jeder weiss, wer Fergie ist, London Bridge, Clumsy, das sind Hits für die Ewigkeit, wohing Clumsy, London Bridge. Ja, seitdem hört man kaum noch was von euch, muss man sagen. Aber ihr arbeitet an einem Album? Nein. Ah, okay. Ich dachte, okay. Weder an einem einzelnen Song noch an einem Album, wegen des Boom, muss man sagen, ist Geschichte. Aber Simon arbeitet noch anscheinend an der Musik, das freut mich, er hat das nicht ganz fallen lassen, wohingegen du ja mittlerweile malst. Muss ich schon gar nicht mehr ansprechen, ist es schon direkt wieder begraben oder? Ich male noch. Ich meine, das Vorteil, dieses Hobby kreilt sich so an mich, weil diese Trocknungszeiten von Ölfarbe so extrem lang sind. Dadurch habe ich eigentlich schon kein Interesse mehr, aber das Bild liegt, diese ganze Male ist noch aufgebaut, weil das Bild immer noch trocknet. Ich verstehe, aber das ist das perfekte Hobby, oder? Du machst zwei Striche und dann, oh, jetzt musst du das lange malen. Lange malen. Lange trocknen, ja. Und dann hast du wieder Zeit, irgendwie Simpsons zu schauen den ganzen Tag. Ja, genau, Sims, Sims zu schauen den ganzen Tag. Sims Let's Plays. Warum zitieren das immer alles? Irgendwie, Nucola kam noch nicht vor.
Muss ich tatsächlich kurze Empfehlung aussprechen, denn wir wurden auf Reddit hingewiesen, wo mittlerweile eigentlich quasi jeder Trend von KI und generiertem Content schon vertreten ist. Aber ein besonderer Post hat mich dann doch aufmerksam werden lassen, nämlich durch KI generierte Seinfeld Folgen auf Twitch läuft 24-7 konstant, wird in Echtzeit generiert, Watch Me Forever heißt es, Nothing Forever und es ist wirklich ein psychedelischer Albtraum, aus dem man nicht aufwachen möchte. Es ist wirklich grandios, weil ich weiß nicht, wie die das schaffen, aber die nicht nur schaffen, die es den Text zu generieren und dass das Sprecher einsprechen, automatisch halt KI-Sprecher, sondern auch die Bilder. Sie klingen wie Jerry Seinfeld. Nein, nein, nein, sie heißen auch nicht Jerry, sondern Larry, die heißen alle leicht anders und auch die Bilder werden generiert, also das ist ganz verrückt für die verschiedenen Figuren und dadurch, dass sie halt immer versuchen, lustig zu sein, entstehen immer ganz unangenehme Situationen, weil die das Timing nicht so ganz raushaben oder so. Bei Seinfeld gibt es immer diese Stand-Up-Bits, wo Larry Seinfeld dann immer sagt so, what do you call a bear with no teeth? Cut nächste Szene im Apartment. Okay. Und du denkst, du wirst einfach hängen gelassen. Ist die spannendste Sendung aller Zeiten. Wirklich, du weißt nie, kriegst du noch eine Pointe oder nicht. Das ist absolut fantastisch. Weil wenn du eine normale Comedy-Show anschaust, du weißt, du wirst Pointen kriegen, gut oder schlecht ist dann die Frage. Aber hier ist überhaupt die Frage, kriege ich überhaupt was am Ende? Ja. Also wenn ich das Bienennest vom Baum ziehe und aufmache, ist überhaupt was drin oder war das alles umsonst? Wurde ich gestochen für nichts? Es ist gleichzeitig maximal unbefriedigend und maximal spannend zu gucken, weil ungesehen. Weil in gewisser Weise, wenn Menschen beteiligt sind, weißt du, das kriegst du mit erwartbarem Unsinn zu tun. Und wenn, also das schauen durchgehend 10.000 Leute live, und wenn mal ein Gag stattfindet, der wirklich Sinn ergibt, dann rastet der Chat komplett aus. Ich liebe das. Es ist fantastisch. Wow! Aber im Grunde ist es doch geil. Ich meine, das ist natürlich alles noch rudimentär, aber stell dir vor, deine Lieblingssendung ist abgesetzt, dann kann man ja einfach sagen, ich schau mir, wird es weiter zufällig generierte oder KI-generierte Folgen an,
damit es noch mehr gibt.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man Sendungen guckt der Sendung wegen
oder weil es einem die wirklich gefällt.
Und dann würde ich behaupten, dass wenn eine KI das genau so hinkriegt ...
Meinst du, das sind ...
Ich meine, du könntest ja sagen, generier mir Herr der Ringe Teil vier.
The Return of Gimli.
So, gib mir The Return of Gimli.
Und dann sagst du, füge das dem Kanon hinzu und dann gib mir Herr der Ringe Teil fünf. Mary's Adventure. So, und dann kannst du nochmal da komplette Geschichten generieren, weil es gibt immer mehr. Es gibt immer mehr. Und der Prompt ist, Mary is the real Lord of the Rings, generated part four. Ja, give me Lord of the Rings with a twist. Herr der Ringe eine recht direkte Geschichte, relativ klar. Relativ straight, Heldenreise, am Ende wird der Böse besiegt. Wunderbar, wenig Überraschungen, eigentlich keine. Frodo ist Sauron. Keine Überraschungen? Keine Überraschungen. Ich bin so langsam, aber sehr hart mit Herr der Ringe. Die einzige Überraschung ist vielleicht, dass Gollum am Ende noch versucht, den Ring zu nehmen. Völlig erwartbar. Auch keine Überraschung. Dass er da ist, ist ein bisschen eine Überraschung, aber nicht, dass er den Weg nehmen will. Man darf Leute nicht Gollum nennen übrigens. Es gab ein Gerichtsurteil, dass Gollum eine Beleidigung ist. Und es gab auch mal einen Fall, wo jemand im Internet so ein Meme gepostet hat mit Bilder von Gollum und daneben Erdogan, so in verschiedenen Gesichtsausdrücken. So, ey, du Gollum ist verboten. Ey, du Gollum ist verboten. Das war nur ein Beispiel. Genau, nein, das ist verboten. Außer du sagst es zu Gollum. Also Andy Serkis kann ich auf der Strasse mit, alter, du Gollum. Weiß ich nicht, würde ich aufpassen. Du Gollum, du bist mir hinten reingefahren, das ist der Moment, als Andy Serkis in mich reingefahren ist, weil ich zu scharf gebremst habe, weil ich rechts diesen In-and-Out-Burger gesehen habe und dachte mir, vielleicht will ich da auch noch einen Burger, will ich einen Burger, und dann habe ich schnell gebremst. Ja, am I in or am I out? Und dann ist Andy Serkis in mich reingefahren und ich habe gesagt, alter, ey du Gollum, fahr mir nicht rein. Bis heute denkst du nach, wie du schlagfertiger hättest reagieren können, aber nie ist dir was eingefallen. Jetzt hast du vielleicht gemerkt, dass es besser so war. Ja, ich habe auch direkt das, ah krass, Andy Serkis ist mir hinten draufgekommen, übersprungen und habe direkt gesagt, ey du Gollum, ohne zu wissen. Und dann habe ich erst gecheckt, weil das immer meine Go-To-Beleidigung war, vor allem Richtigsteil, dann erst gemerkt, ah okay, Andy Serkis ist mir jetzt die Person, die mir reingefallen. War er stutzbetrunken? Komplett betrunken. Der muss ja immer so viel trinken, damit deine Stimme funktioniert. Der muss ja immer so Pfirsich-Sirup trinken oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Und da war halt auch Alkohol drin. Das heißt, der war eigentlich im Set immer komplett hacke dicht. Für alle Szenen, wie der sich einen Fisch fängt im Fluss, war so nicht geplant. Der ist einfach nur umgefallen und hat gezappelt. Ach so, er wollte gar keinen Fisch fangen. Er ist hinter Flasche hinterhergesprungen. Aus Versehen Fisch? Ja, egal. Auf jeden Fall gab es diesen Internetpost mit Gollum, parallel geschoppt zu Erdogan, verschiedene Gesichtsausdrücke, und dann war auch die Frage, Verleumdungsklage und so, kann ja ganz schnell immer schiefgehen. Erdogan nimmt immer schnell mit. Und dann hat sich Peter Jackson zu Wort gemeldet und meinte, auf den Bildern ist nicht Gollum zu sehen, sondern Smeagol. Ja, so, das wäre jetzt auch meine Frage gewesen. Und Smeagol ist eine positiv konnotierte Figur oder eine zumindest leidende, nicht negativ konnotierte Figur. Doch. Smeagol ist ja der, der korrumpiert wird vom Ring. Brudermörder. Der ist ja das Opfer des Rings. Ja, aber nur durch den Ring. Brüdermorder. Ja, aber nur durch den Ring, ja nicht, wann sich's erhebst. Nee, verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich verstehe deine anklagende Stimme. Aber gut, es ist ein leicht zu korrumpierender Mensch, also ein einfaches Gemüt. Du kannst Menschen nicht dafür verurteilen, dass sie leicht zu verführen sind. Ich finde schon. Ich finde, genau das kann man machen. Aber da stehen wir jetzt, glaube ich, auf dem Schlauch. Also jetzt haben wir uns in eine Sackgasse manövriert. Wir stehen gemeinsam auf dem Schlauch?
Ich glaube nicht, dass du so... Also du stehst gerade in der Hinsicht auf dem Schlauch, dass dir das richtige Sprichwort nicht einfällt.
Naja, genau. Also ich wollte sagen, wir stehen uns in eine Sackgasse manövriert.
Vor Gerichtse, Herr Tietse, was genau meinten Sie, als Sie, nachdem Sie Andy Serkis als Dougollum bezeichnet haben, mit wir stehen alle auf dem Schlauch? Naja, also wenn Feuerwehrmänner auf dem Schlauch stehen, dann suchen sie ja nicht nach einer Lösung, sondern sie haben sich wie wir gerade in den Sackgasse manövriert. Das ist ein Problem, was erstmal überwunden werden muss. Das kommt aus der Feuerwehrwelt, oder was? Ja, aber dann benutzen wir es falsch. Ich stehe auf dem Schlauch, heißt ja eigentlich, mir fällt das gar nicht ein. Ja. Aber wenn Feuerwehr auf dem Schlauch stehen würde, würden sie das so benutzen, wie ich gerade das meinte. Dass wir gerade nicht vorankommen. Wir kommen gerade nicht voran. Es geht gerade nicht weiter. Okay, naja, ich verstehe schon. Ja, das meine ich eigentlich. Ich meine, da haben wir uns jetzt gerade verstritten. Aber du kannst natürlich so ein bisschen Druck aufbauen, ne, wenn du auf dem Schlauch stehst und dann kommt mehr raus. Ist das jetzt sexuell? Je nachdem. Ich meine, Feuerwehr ist generell ein recht sexueller Beruf. Also jetzt nicht notwendigerweise immer in jeder einzelnen Kanzlei. Nee, das sagt man nicht. Feuer, Flamme und Söhne, die Feuerwehrkanzlei. Ich meine, die kriegen jeden Tag einen neuen Fall rein. Ja, das ist die richtige Frage. Also im ganzen Eilstein, ich weiß auch nicht genau, wie die Feuerwehr funktioniert. Von daher denke ich, es ist halt so ähnlich wie eine Anwaltskanzlei. Der Mandant ruft an, sagt, passen Sie mal auf, wir können hier nicht abgehört werden. Also, Sie können mir alles verraten. Diese Leitung ist gesichert. Das ist hier ein Feuerwehrgeheimnis. Niemand kann erfahren, was hier passiert. Okay, nämlich, es brennt hier nämlich gerade und genau, da wollte ich mich einfach mal erkundigen, so angenommen, ich hätte das jetzt selber angezündet. Okay, wie gesagt, nur damit Sie es wissen, Sie können mir alles erzählen, die Leitung ist frei. Wir stehen auf dem Schlauch. Niemand steht auf diesem Schlauch gerade. Die Leitung ist unangezapft, verstehen Sie? Ah ja, okay. Also der Schlauch, machen Sie
den Schlauch voll. Alles klar. Mit Informationen
und allem. Ja. Ist das Haus
aktuell, brennt es aktuell noch.
Es brennt aktuell, brennt es noch. Alles klar.
Ich dachte, es würde schneller gehen
und Sie würden jetzt irgendwie schon
Löschzug losschicken oder sowas.
Es ist erstmal ein schwieriger Fall, auf jeden Fall.
Wir müssen natürlich gucken, wie wir
Sie der Jury präsentieren.
Stehen Sie selbst in Flammen, würden sie sagen? Ich würde sagen, noch nicht, aber ich wüsste jetzt auch nicht den schnellsten Weg runter und ich glaube, es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit, a matter of time. Es wäre natürlich für das Urteil besser, wenn sie ein paar Verletzungen davon trägen. Okay, deswegen habe ich die angerufen. Das sage ich Ihnen als Ihr Feuerwehrmann, dass es vor Gericht natürlich besser aussieht, wenn Sie ein bisschen mitgenommen sind. Ja, ich meine, deswegen habe ich Sie angerufen. Das sage ich Ihnen als Ihr Feuerwehrmann, dass es vor Gericht natürlich besser aussieht, wenn
Sie ein bisschen mitgenommen sind. Ja, ich meine, deswegen ruhe ich Sie an
von Funkeflamme Söhne. Absolut, absolut.
Aber Sie haben die Expertise, ich ja nicht. Absolut, Sie haben genau die richtige Entscheidung getroffen. Ja, Entschuldigung.
Sorry, das ist meine Frau.
Nein, ich würde sagen, die Aussage verweigern an der Stelle.
Ich würde ihr raten, die Aussage zu verweigern an der Stelle.
Schatz, Aussage verweigern an der Stelle. Ich würde ihr raten, die Aussage zu verweigern an der Stelle.
Schatz, Aussage verweigern lieber.
Ja, ich glaube, er hat sie zur Kenntnis genommen.
Ich würde sagen, der Fall ist in der Tasche.
Wir kriegen das hin.
Okay, und kommen Sie zum Löschen vorbei oder gar nicht?
Der Kriegstermin ist in acht Monaten.
Ich würde sagen, bis dahin sammeln wir alles und machen Sie Fotos von einem.
Ja.
Tschüss.
Tschüss. Tschüss. Wir verbeugen uns gerade, seht ihr nicht? Wir verbeugen uns für das Improvisationstheater. Blumenstrauss fliegt in den Raum. Stefan versucht ihn zu fangen, aber nicht ganz. Fallen gelassen. Doch zu hoch. Jetzt versuche ich hierher zu hechten. Bühnenkante zu hoch. Oh nein, jetzt versuche ich hier zu hechten. Ups, hoch.
Bühnenkante zu hoch.
Oh nein, jetzt wird viel gekullert erstmal.
Jetzt wird gekullert.
Ui, ui, ui.
So dunkel, ich sehe ihn kaum noch.
Wo bist du, Stefan?
Wo bist du? Ich sehe ihn nicht mehr.
Ich sehe ihn nicht mehr. Arme der Höhen.
Kannst du dein Handylicht anmachen?
Handylicht wird angekommen.
Handylicht, Handylicht, Handylicht.
Jetzt sehe ich dich.
Okay, nehm den Arm, nehm den Arm, nehm meinen Arm.
Und zimt hoch, und wir verweigen uns wieder. Und wunderbar, super. Ich freue mich, der Januar ist vorbei. Das freut mich auch für dich, das freut mich auch für dich. Ich habe den Januar verflucht, aber rückblickend versöhnt. Der Januar ist doch nicht der Montag des Jahres, könnte man so sagen. Ja, und wenn er dann mal vorbei ist, dann ist man auch gar nicht so, ja, man guckt gar nicht mehr so böse drauf.
Februar ist ja Dienstag.
Ja.
Und jetzt langsam wird es, ich bin gespannt, wie du es weitermachst. Mach mal diese Kette weiter.
Februar ist Dienstag.
Du wirst irgendwie immer am Schlauch stehen.
März ist Mittwoch, April ist Donnerstag.
Dann kommen die vielen Freitagmonate. Mai ist Freitag, Juni ist Samstag, Juli, natürlich auch Samstag, August, Freitag, September, Samstag, Oktober, November auch Samstag, Feiertage, Brückentage. Und Dezember ist Samstag. Sonntag. Und der 31. Dezember ist ein Sonntag. Nicht zwangsläufig, aber okay, metaphorisch. Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja, ja. Soll ich das so auf eine Tasse drucken und so an Büros verkaufen? Nein? Ich verstehe immer nicht, warum du immer an diese TassengedGedanken sofort so schnell denkst. Die Menschen brauchen Tassen. Das stimmt tatsächlich, ja. Jeder braucht Tassen. Ja, aber es gibt ja auch Tassenhersteller, die sich zurücknehmen können mit bedruckten Dingen, sondern einfach Tassenherstellen. Schicke Tassen. Bist du so ein Typ, der so bedruckte Tassen zu Hause hat? Ja, jede Gelegenheit für einen Gag, immer, überall. Bei mir auf dem Schlüssel, auf meinem Haustürschlüssel
ist ein kleiner Gag abgeschrieben,
da steht dann irgendwie, ich bin fleissig wie ein Bienchen.
Gut, für die Pointe war kein Platz mehr.
Also es ist wie eine AI-generierte Design-Weltfolge,
dein Schlüsselbund.
Hast du so lustige Gags in deiner Wohnung,
eine Fussmatte, wo irgendwie draufsteht?
Busy, busy vielleicht, ich bin busy. Du darfst mich mit Füssen treten oder so eine Fussmatte? Ja, finde ich gut. Ja, so eine Fussmatte mit wie, Achtung, ich bin nackt? Ja, okay, nee, ist ja ein Brainstorming.
Das soll ja gar nicht irgendwie despektierlich klingen oder so, aber ist ja nur ein Brainstorming.
Schatzkiste, unter dieser Fussmatte, sowas halt.
Ja, ja, so ein grosses rotes Kreuz, irgendwie sowas.
Nee, da steht einfach nur Schatzkiste ist unter dieser Fussmatte begraben, Punkt. Punkt, Punkt. So, um auch klar zu sagen, das war es mit den Informationen. Jetzt lachen vorbei, jetzt geht der Ernst los. Und dann drunter, nee, nee, Scherz, ich bin nur eine Fussmatte. Ja, oder wenn man sie dann so auf der Unterseite ist, dann so, nee, Scherz. Sorry, dass es nicht klar deutlich geworden ist. Entschuldigung, dass es zu diesem Missverständnis zwischen uns gekommen ist. Warum in diesem holprigen Deutsch, in diesem Schatzkiste ist unter dieser Fussmatte begraben. Eine, eine Schatzkiste befindet sich eingegraben unter dieser Fußmatte. Das ist nicht so gelegen formuliert, findest du nicht? Du, auf einer Fußmatte, ich bin Tassen gewohnt, auf einer Fußmatte ist wahnsinnig viel Platz. Ich komme ja ursprünglich vom T-Shirt und bin dann zur Tasse gegangen, was eine Umstellung war, und jetzt muss ich wieder zur Fußmatte und da hast du wahnsinnig viel Platz. Da kriegst du gar nicht genug raus, um das vollzukriegen. Ja, nee. Okay, alles klar. Ob ihr wirklich richtig steht. Seht ihr, wenn die Tür aufgeht? Das geht doch, oder? Das kann man machen. Das kann man machen. Das ist rechtlich geschützt, aber kann man machen. Wie rechtlich geschützt, da kommt Elton oder was und sagt ... Bei mir steht einfach nur, du Gollum. Dann kommt die Polizei. Und dann ist so ein kleiner Ring, so wie der so runtergefallen ist. Und wer sich bückt, verliert. Ich habe keinen einzigen Gag in meiner Wohnung mit so diesem Typ. Also keine Tassen. Weil du stilvoll bist. Keine Wandtattoos. Du hast Anspruch.
Ich habe keine Lust auf so Gags. Und ich finde auch, wenn man einigermaßen so in der groben Richtung was mit Comedy macht, man will auch nicht dann zu Hause, wenn man auf diesen einen Gag starren muss. Ja, bei mir ist das Problem, ich fühle mich auch in meiner Wohnung nicht so ganz zu Hause, weil ich habe jetzt so eine Art, ich habe jetzt einen Mitbewohner. Und also es ist kein Mensch, es ist ein High-End Gaming-PC. Ach so, ich dachte ein High-End-Hund. High-End-Hamster, Cutting-Edge-Technology, State-of-the-Art. Okay, was heisst das? Sechzehn Zoll, 16 Zoll Hamster, Surround Sound, alles drin.
Ein Zoll Zähnchen, fünf Zoll Bäckchen und 300 Gramm purer Hamster einfach. Und nein, es ist hier, ich habe vor einiger Zeit habe ich die Möglichkeit gehabt, mir einen ganz tollen Gaming-PC zusammenzubauen und der ist viel zu krass für mich. Viel, viel zu krass. Hast du den für deinen Twitch-Game bezogen? Mittlerweile benutze ich ihn dafür, aber nee, wir haben ihn gesponsert bekommen sozusagen. Der ist viel, viel zu krass. Viel zu krass. Und der hat halt so, der ist halt so ein richtiger Gaming-PC, riesengroß, und der hat halt auch immer dieses Leuchen, dieses Leuchten halt, dieses Gaming. Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Warum ist die Ästhetik von Gaming immer gleich Neonfarben, diese LED-Farben, RGB? Ja, das ist so ein Need-for-Speed-Neon-Ding. Und ich fremdele halt so ein bisschen, weil der steht jetzt in meiner Wohnung und ... Er sieht aus wie bei 2001, so wie Hell. Ja, das ist halt wie wenn du so eine Disco-Kugel in deinem Wohnzimmer hast, aber eigentlich nur ein ruhiger, zurückgezogener Typ bist.
Aber es ist die einzige Lampe, die du hast.
Ich stelle mir so vor, der ist so mega unterfordert, einfach so ein riesen Big Brain, was du die ganze Zeit nachts, gehst du dann nochmal irgendwie, wachst du auf, gehst zum Klo, kommst dann in diesem Raum vorbei, wo dann hinten diese eine Lampe, die ist so anstarrt. Ich könnte jetzt alles ausrechnen. Und was er denkt ist, ich könnte alles, ich könnte die Weltformel ausrechnen. Da dessen gucke ich dir zu, wie du zu verschlafen jetzt zum Klo gehst. Es ist eigentlich grausam, das ist wie wenn man so einen Job macht, für den man viel zu überqualifiziert ist. Und die haben dann so, ja, Herr Rudolfs, Entschuldigung, Herr Jobs, mein Drucker, da ist jetzt die rote Tinte, heisst es da, dass da die, aber ihr habt es jetzt schon mal austauscht und jetzt drückt der immer noch, ist das, können Sie mal mal schauen den Drucker, Herr Jobs. Herr Permaneder, bitte, können Sie da nicht jemanden fragen?
Herr Jobs, Sie kennen sich doch mit Computern aus. Ja, genau so fühlt sich, glaube ich, dieses Riesending bei dir. Ja, wenn ich sag, frag mich www.purn.h. Ja, ich hab seit P, Auto vervollständige ich dir das.
U, B, ich dir das. U-B-Punkt-Org. Org-G-O-V-G-O-V-Enter. .gov.uk Oder so, ich mache die Taschenrechner-App auf. Fünf mal vier. 20 plus drei. Ja, was ist das wohl? Ist gleich. Was ist das wohl? Flonti, was kann das wohl sein, 20 plus drei? Du musst fast nicht ausreden, du musst nur die Wörter zusammensetzen. Was ist 20 plus drei? Nee, Flotin, guck mich mal an. Guck mir in die Augen, guck mir Alienware Dell 30px19 in die Augen, in mein leuchtendes eines Auge. Wo ich die Farbe ändern kann, im Farbverlauf, wie diese Rolltreppen, die es über den Quellen gibt. So passiv-aggressives Farbe ändern. Jetzt bin ich blau, aber wenn du gleich noch mal guckst, bin ich rot. 20 plus 3. 23, du. Okay, danke. Aber so ist das ein bisschen, weil interessanterweise leuchtet der auch, wenn er aus ist. Und das ist so ein bisschen so, ich liege im Bett, ich liege im Bett, will schlafen, währenddessen unter meinem Schreibtisch wirklich so eine Party und überall die Lichter und diese Lichtstreifen überall wie so ein Blaulicht in meiner ganzen Wohnung. Die Kühlung, die Wasserkühlung. Dann machst du den Laptop so, wenn du den Tower so aufmachst. Die Wasserpumpe und ich so. Du hast so ein Lachen auch. Ich würde jetzt ins Bett gehen übrigens. Ja, ja, das ist klar, kein Problem, kein Problem. Ich leg mich jetzt hin. Kein Problem, wir machen nicht mehr so. Die Lampen sind ein bisschen hell. Machst du Schlafmaske oder so? Okay, weil eigentlich bist du ja mein Computer. Ja, aber so viel Porno, wie du heute geguckt hast, da kannst du ja aus dem dem Soko schlafen, ne? Da kann doch jemand jetzt gut schlafen, ne? Okay, nein, aber ich meine, eigentlich solltest ja du irgendwie mir gehorchen, oder nicht? Ach, okay, ich, okay. Und ich habe halt dieses krasse Partymobil bei mir in der Wohnung und ich bin ein bisschen eingeschichtet, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich kann das genau nachvollziehen. Ich bin ein bisschen eingeschziehen. Eingeschichtet, du bist nicht mehr der Herr im Haus. Deswegen sagt man ja, wenn man sich einen High-End-Gaming-PC anschafft, sagt dem von Anfang an, du bist der Alpha. Ich habe die Phase, habe ich verpasst. Die Phase habe ich verpasst. Du musst es richtig erziehen. Die Zugfahrt war das Beste, weil ich habe den in Hamburg bekommen, das war eigentlich die schlimmste Zugfahrt meines Lebens, ich habe den in Hamburg bekommen und musste ihn dann nach Köln bringen und dann hab ich den im ICE neben mich gesetzt in so einem Sechserabteil, neben mich so und er war so gross. Und viele Leute kamen vorbei, haben ihn gestreichelt. Da musst du direkt, du musst direkt sagen, ne, also ich bin der Herr im Haus. Und dann hat auch einer tatsächlich, meinte auch so, ach krass, was für einen Prozessor hat der? Fünfer. Wie, das ist kein Prozessor. Gehen Sie bitte. Bitte gehen Sie. Und das Beste war, mir gegenüber saß eine ältere Frau und die war besorgt, weil der Computer so gross war, dass er nicht vollständig Platz gefunden hat auf dem Sitz. Er stand ein bisschen über. Also er lief ein wenig Gefahr, umzufallen auf dem Boden, weil es so gross war, dass der Sitz für ihn zu klein war. Und jetzt war es so, immer wenn... Du warst nicht besorgt? Ich war nicht besorgt, weil ich habe mir überlegt, wo ich mich hinsetze. Und zwar habe ich mich mit dem Rücken zur Fahrtrichtung gesetzt, so dass wenn der Zug beschleunigt, der Rechner in den Sitz gedrückt wird. Weil die Gefahr ist ja, ne, Entschuldigung, wenn er bremst. Entschuldigung, wenn er bremst. Dein größter Feind bei dieser Theorie ist der Kopfbahnhof. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Wir wenden. Was? Ich dachte, das grösste Problem ist das Bsen. Und dann setzte ich mit dem Rücken zur Fahrtrichtung, sodass beim Bremsen in den Sitz gedrückt wurde. Clever, clever, clever. Die Dame mir gegenüber hat das aber nicht so ganz verstanden. Und hat immer, wenn der Zug gebremst hat, ihre Hände so schützend vor den Rechner gehalten. Rückblickend um. Und ich dachte mir immer, an welchem Punkt sage ich, weil es ist ja nie was passiert. Und ich dachte mir jedes Mal, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Also ich habe das doch unter Kontrolle. Aber jedes Mal so. Wie viel Angst muss sie haben? Aber war sie besorgt um den PC oder um ihre Gesundheit? Sie hätte das glaube ich nicht überlegt. Nein, nein, sie saß gegenüber. Dieser Alienware Tower hat ja irgendwie so Stacheln oder sowas. Das ist auch so wie so ein Morgenstern, der auf dich zurollt. So ein offenes Laufwerk, wo so Klingen einfach rotieren die ganze Zeit. Nee, sie saß ja mir gegenüber, nicht dem Rechner und deswegen null Gefahr, aber sie war so besorgt, wo kriegt man denn so einen großen Computer her? Ja, wir sind ja auch für das Berufliche... Ja, same, meine Zugstimme aufgesetzt.
Es ist einfach schlafen gestimmt. Mit offenen Augen.
Und die ganze Fahrt mir war das so unangenehm, dass ich wirklich überlegt habe, zu gehen,
weil die hatte so viel Angst über etwas, was nicht passieren kann.
Wie traurig, aber es tut mir sehr leid, dass sie das Gefühl hatte, das muss man erst mal respektieren. Ja, aber dass sie sich dachte, sie muss sich jetzt um den Computer kümmern. Das weiß ich nicht. Man braucht ein ganzes Dorf, um einen Computer aufzuziehen. Alle müssen mit anpacken. Alle müssen mit anpacken. Ich finde gut, dass du diese riesengottgleiche Rechenmaschine da hast. Und dann ist da so eine ältere Frau, die ihre Hände so schützend davor hält, hat ja auch irgendwie was Mensch-versus-Technologie-artiges. Ist eigentlich ein gutes Bild. Ist ein schönes Bild. Und rückwirkend hat sie ja auch recht behalten. Du bist jetzt diesem Technologie-Monster ausgeliefert. Ich bin komplett ausgeliefert. Der so langsam irgendwie, glaube ich, dich anfangen wird zu manipulieren und zu seinen höheren Zwecken zu gebrauchen. Ich glaube, er wird so anfangen, so Gedanken in dir zu sähen, damit du, vielleicht schließt du ihn irgendwann mal eine krasse AI an oder du bringst ihn irgendwo hin, in so ein Rechenzentrum, in so ein Server-Farm. Ich habe schon überlegt, weil so der erste Gedanke natürlich, wenn man so einen krassen Rechner hat, dachte ich mir so, jetzt mache ich Bitcoin. Bitcoin Farming. Und ich dachte mir, dass der mir das so, so wenn ich suche, so P, O und er so Bitcoin meinen. R, meinten sie Bitcoin meinen? Sie meinten Bitcoin. N, meinten sie Bitcoin meinen? Nee, Flo und die jetzt im Ernst, sie meinten Bitcoin. H, ich weiß nicht, was du eingeben willst.
Die Autokorrektur drückt dich einfach.
Lass mich bitte schürfen.
Lass mich tief in den Bitcoin-Berg hinuntersteigen.
Und wir graben und graben, weil ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung.
Die PCs waren zu gierig.
Und sie schürfen zu tief. Und sie wussten nicht, was sie wecken. Bitt und Beid. Hi, ich bin Bitt oder ich bin Beid. Nein, und die Welt war nie wieder wie sie vorher war. Alle haben so ein Ballrockartiges, so eine nischige Folge mit unseren weirden Herr-der-Ringe-Referenzen, aber der Ballrock von Ulgul, den dachtet ihr jetzt. Zu dessen können sie Bid und Bid, die freundlichen Brüder. Hey! Hi! Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam! Was war das? Bidüm! Bidüm! Bid! Bid! Mein Name ist Bid. Aber dann gib mir doch einfach für meine Twitch-Ambitionen diesen PC. Ja, ich will den nie wieder transportieren. Also komme ich bei dir an und du hältst so Schützen die Hände. Ich so, Stefan, ich habe das alles unter Kontrolle. Nee, Vorsicht, Vorsicht, wenn jetzt wieder mein Bananenbaum Blätter abwirft, hältst alles Schützen so drüber. Ja, ich tu so Netz baue ich da drüber, oder wie über Tschernobyl, so ein Sarkophag, so ein grosses Ding, so eine Kapsel, damit nichts passieren kann. Ja, ich war, ich habe noch nie eine krasse Rechenmaschine bei mir gehabt, aber ich würde mich, glaube ich, auch schlecht fühlen. Auch generell, glaube ich, ist, also ein bisschen mit Kanon auf Spatzen, dafür, dass Menschen dann einfach nur Unterhaltung haben wollen und irgendwie zocken wollen und so. Das ist so viel Energie, was da drauf geht und so krasse Rechenpower. Die Wissenschaftler, aber das kannst du machen vielleicht. Ja genau, man kann das so zur Verfügung stellen. Soweit du den nicht benutzt kannst, das habe ich damals mit meinem alten iMac, mit meiner Schaufel, alten Gerübe, da habe ich das gemacht Und jetzt mit dem Bugatti nicht. Aber ich meine, ich bin aktuell, so weit bin ich noch nicht, ich habe mir nämlich einen Finger geschnitten. Und ich weiß nicht, wir kommen jetzt in moralische Grenzbereiche. Selbstverletzung. Ich meine, wenn du jetzt, sag ich mal, du kochst was. Also ich habe was gekocht und ich habe geschnitten etwas. Und es ist reingefallen. Und dann habe ich mir halt hier am Daumen, habe ich mir sauber halt ein Stück Haut abgeschnitten. Und es war direkt ab. Hast du nur für dich gekocht oder für zwei? Eins nach dem anderen. Weil jetzt ne? Kannibalismus. Und ich habe dann geguckt, wo das Stück Haut ist.
Oh mein Gott.
Weil ich hab's auch erst nicht bemerkt.
Ich hab dann erst bemerkt so, und dann hab ich das Stück Haut nicht gefunden, weil es hat auch nicht sofort geblutet.
Das ist ja dieser Moment, bevor Dinge bluten.
Ich weiss auch nicht, was das für ein Moment ist.
Du hast ja, wenn du dich reinschneidest, dann ist erst so, oh, war nichts?
Und dann so
kommt das Blut
so angerannt.
Wie vor allem, weil man immer eine Ader trifft.
Wo sind überall Adern?
Und warum ist es nicht instant da? Wo kommt das denn her?
Ja, ja, ich verstehe.
Kann es sein, dass es Blut nicht
gibt und der Körper so 100 Milligramm hat und das immer erst zu der Wunde hingeschickt werden muss, dass in der Milz so oh shit, shit, shit, sonst fällt das auf, rein da, rein da, rein da. Die Milz ist der Blutversorger des Körpers. Ja, vielleicht niemand weiss, wofür die gut ist. Ich habe so krasse Milzrhythmusstörungen, die ganze Zeit schon solche, meine Milz, die, manchmal im Schlaf spiel ja auch meine Milz, wie sie dann so Gas gibt. Oder wenn ich Kaffee trinke auch. Wenn die Milz wieder loslegen. Und ich habe dieses Stück Haut nicht gefunden. Wie würdest du das sagen, kann man es dann noch essen oder nicht? Ist es Autokannibalismus, wenn du ein Stück Haut von dir isst? Nee, als ... Ich habe zwar noch nie an den Fingernägeln gekaut oder sowas, aber wenn ich eine Wunde habe an den Fingern oder sowas, bin ich schon so ein Blutwecksauger. Ja, ja. Da kommen so kleine Vampire mehr raus und sowas. Und deswegen bin ich da so ein bisschen vorurteilsfrei. Also wenn ich so ein bisschen Vorhaut, also Fingervorhaut abschneide und es in den Nudeln in der Bollo landet, dann ... Kein Problem. Alles klar, gut. Aber ich wäre jetzt ... Ich will es nicht von anderen beim Essen haben. Wenn du für uns beide gekocht hättest ... Du würdest es nicht mehr servieren. Was viele nicht wissen, Flo und ich machen ja immer so einen Kochabend jetzt jede Woche, wo du dann schön für uns zu kochst. So letztens schön Kaninchen für uns gemacht, das war ganz toll. Und Hamster gab es auch einmal. Und ja, immer irgendwie komischerweise das Haustier. Und da hast du schön gekocht für uns und da hätte ich jetzt nicht so gern deine Haut drin. Ich bin bei anderer Menschenhaut. welche, welche, meine eigentliche Angst war gar nicht, oh das ist jetzt super eklig, wenn ich das esse, so Autokannibalismus, glaube ich, ist ja okay, rechtlich abgesichert. Ist das so? Ich dachte mir nur so, was ist, wenn das jetzt richtig gut schmeckt? Also was ist jetzt, wenn das wirklich das Leckerste wäre, was ich je gegessen habe? Ein bisschen wie Hühnchen. Vor allem da dachte ich mir, das ist doch eine Geschichte, oder so jemand, oh, das fällt rein und dann plötzlich, oder stell dir vor, die Gäste sind da, du schneidest Zwiebel, schneidest dir ein Stück Haut ab, es geht in den Topf, du findest es nicht mehr, die Gäste sind schon da, du kannst nicht alles nochmal neu machen. Was ist, das ist ja fantastisch. Das ist ja köstlich. Das habe ich ja. Köstlich. Oh, ja. Was ist das denn, diese kleine Note, dieses Umami? Ja, ja. Immer auch dieses Zeigen aufs Essen. Nicken und zeigen. Und dann so zurückfallen in den Stuhl. Oh, oh. Ich kriege richtig Hunger. Ich kriege richtig Hunger gerade. Also, diese wirklich, das ist noch kein Satz formuliert. Nein, da kommt an die, du bist in solcher Ekstase, dass du keine klaren Sätze rausbringen kannst.
Das ist ja, je mehr Grammatik, desto schlechter gefällt es dir eigentlich. Aber die Grenze ist, glaube ich, wirklich, kochst du für andere, das ist ja der Merksatz, fällt dein Fleisch in die Supp und du kochst für andere Lasses. Weißt du?
Die deutsche Sprache gebrochen für nichts, nur weil du es kannst, einfach nur aus reinem Machtmissbrauch heraus. Das war die Idee. Fällt dein Fleisch in die Supp und du kochst für andere Lasses. auch und trotzdem auch ungelehrt da hätte man wenn man las es wenn man vor allem wenn man
nicht mehr reimen will hätte man auch einfach das viel deutlicher und besser formulieren können. Aber das, das könnte ich mir vorstellen. Also zum Beispiel Bear, die Serie war recht erfolgreich. The Bear. At the the. The Bear. Warum, why? No, it's the bear. It's messier. It's more. It's more.. Ich würde ihn gerne nochmal drehen, nur mit dem Twist. Nur mit dem Twist. Und vor allem, also so kann ja Hannibal anfangen oder so, Hannibal Reimagined. Und irgendwann hat er dann nicht mehr genug Fleisch selber, er schneidet dann immer, kocht dann immer und schneidet immer was von seiner Haut, aber irgendwann hat er nicht genug. Er haut an sich. Ich brauche ein Opfer. Ich brauche mehr Haut. Ich brauche ein Opfer.
Ich brauche mehr Haut.
Gebt mir mehr Haut.
Und dann sieht man so, wie die Gäste essen, reiben sich so die Bäuche, lecker, lecker,
verlassen die Tür zum Restaurant, die Tür fällt zu hinter den Gästen, die rausgehen
und an der Glastür hängt Aushilfe gesucht.
Und die Musik deutet schon an. Ja, ja, das stimmt. Der Zuschauer ahnt schon, was gleich passiert. Schnitt, Horizont, Meer, ein einsames Schiff. Ein einsames Schiff, ein Pirat im Sonnenuntergang.
Ja, wir hatten zwei halbe Filme und dachten uns, wir können ja nicht einen halben Film veröffentlichen.
Ich finde das fantastisch. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das so offen erzählen sollen, aber ich habe jetzt mal herausgefunden, weil Flo und ich sind große Fans von Filmmusik und Orchestern.
Und ich habe jetzt mal einfach, ich will jetzt nicht sagen welches, aber ein Orchester, ein echtes Orchester angefragt, wie toll er denn eine Aufnahme wäre für ein, sagen wir mal rein hypothetisch, ein Podcast-Intro, ein Podcast-Ufo-Intro, um es mal vage zu formulieren. Das Podcast-Ufo-Projekt mit Stefan-Tisofr und den Will-Intro. Zum Beispiel. Und es ist super bezahlbar. Ich weiß nicht, was das über unsere Kulturindustrie aussagt. Aussagt, ich bin nur der Meinung, es ist sehr wenig Geld für einen Haufen Orchestermitglieder, Mitgliederinnen. Und lass das machen.
Lass uns Klaus Badelt fragen, ob er ein Podcast-Intro für uns macht.
Der Komponist ja von Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da diesen tollen Aspekt Podcast-Hörer-Internen. Wir sagen ja, so, jetzt kommt das Intro von Klaus. Jetzt sagen wir jede Folge. Vielen Dank an Klaus für das Intro. Ich hätte Bock auf so eine epische Abzahl. Aber es ist schon ein bisschen sehr angeberisch. Unsere tollen Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer schicken uns immer ganz tolle Intros zu. Und dann hauen wir sie einfach mit Klaus Badet um die Ohren. Es ist vielleicht so ein bisschen das Thema der Folge. Ihr müsst euch nicht vergleichen. Genau wie der Rechner einfach sowas wie, ja, Klaus Badet spielt bei meiner Hochzeit. Einfach epische Abenteuermusik und dann kommen wir mit, ich bin gestern ihm zugefahren und dann hat er einen. Mir ist eine Münze runtergefallen. Mir ist eine Münze runtergefallen. Ich wollte am Automaten mir einen Milky Way kaufen und dann ist mir die Münze runtergefallen.
Aber fragen Sie sich nicht auch manchmal, warum, warum man das machen sollte und ob man es kann, ob man es dann auch sollte.
Diese Frage möchte ich Ihnen stellen.
Und ich weiss nicht warum, aber die Münze, ich rieb sie am Automaten und ich hatte das Gefühl, dass es besser funktioniert, obwohl es eine reine Illusion ist.
Ram, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. Wollen wir nicht mal so eine History-Folge machen, wo wir mal so spielen, als ob wir in einem anderen Jahrzehnt sein würden, als wir eigentlich sind. mit zwei Rollen.
Ich bin Heiner Brandt, Heiner Brandt. Mein Name ist August Rodenbach. Heiner Brandt und August Rodenbach reden über die Eisenbahn. Die Eisenbahnstrecke von Nürnberg nach Hamburg. Heute führe Nürnberg die erste Eisenbahn. Allein das, glaube ich, kann man sich nicht anhören. Das geht drei Stunden,
weil es eine Special-Folge ist. Würdet ihr euch das anhören?
Ja oder nein, der Chat kann jetzt abstimmen.
So geil, dass 20 Jahre Rundfunkgeschichte
stattgefunden hat, bevor jemand gesagt hat,
Leute, geht nicht so nah ans Mikrofon ran, bitte!
Einfach, ihr könnt euch...
Einfach nehmt ein Stück Abstand.
Alles klar, dann nehmen wir...
Ach so, dann können wir ein bisschen... Ah ja, okay. Alles klar. Gut. Stalingrad. Nun, die Wehrmacht sitzt fest. Einfach alles anders. Gibt's ja in The King's Speech die Szene, wo er extra so ... Die Wehrmacht steht auf dem Schlauch. Ja, die King's Speech, genau, du machst... Jeder weiss es zweimal den Surfergruss. Wir sind Podcast-Bundin, ich weiß nicht, wenn wir so große Gesten... Du machst zweimal den Surfergruss, genau. Zwei Surfergrüssen, Grüsse, zwei Surfergrüsse Abstand. Wenn ihr mimickt, dass ihr telefoniert, ältere Semester, ich included, würden immer noch Zeigefinger, Ja, das Horn. würden Daumen und kleinen Finger wegstrecken voneinander und ans Ohr halten. Genau, das Hörnchen. Und das nehmt ihr, streckt nach vorne und das macht ihr zweimal und das ist der Abstand, den wir brauchen vom Mikrofon. Für unser Mikrofon hier wäre das aber nicht gut, dass ein Nahbesprechungsmikrofonen flogen. Du sagst, neuere Semester mimen das Smartphone, oder wie? Das habe ich neulich mal gesehen. Eine Mutter hat das Kind gefragt, wie würdest du mimiken zu ... Oder ist die Gestik, ich weiß nicht, was das deutsche Wort ist. So tun, als ob. Ja, aber ein bisschen schwierig, ungelenk. Ich glaube, mimiken ist ein Wort. I don't know. Ich weiß es nicht. Also, so tun, als ob du telefonierst, aber mit deinen Händen nur. Und sie nahm es wie ein iPhone in die Hand. Also sie hatte quasi, das ist diese Schaufel, der Schaufelbagger, der Daumen auf der anderen Seite, wie du telefonierst. So hat sie das so getan. Das ist ja interessant, weil es ist ja nicht nur eine Änderung der Geste, sondern auch eine Änderung des Objektverständnisses, weil unser Horn imitiert ja den Hörer, wohingegen die moderne Variante imitiert das Halten des Gegenstands. Also es ist ja von, es ist ja genau wie wenn du die Pistole so mit Zeigefinger zeigst. Eigentlich müssen sie die flache Hand eigentlich nehmen, um das iPhone nachzumachen. Genau, um das iPhone selber, den Gegenstand selber zu imitieren. Und das ist interessant, es ist weniger abstrakt, man hält es nur noch in der Hand. Oder es ist abstrakter. Dann hat sie den älteren Mann gefragt, was war das eigentlich für eine Situation, wo du auf der Fußgängerzone stehst und dieser Frau dabei zuschaust, wie sie es eigenständig ihre Studie zum als wäre es ob, ob wäre es als. Machst du es nicht manchmal, das ist einfach, wenn du, manchmal gehe ich in Häuser rein. Wenn du wenn du interessante Leute findest, dann gerne, verfolg die. Nee, ich gehe einfach in Häuser rein, ab und zu. Ich gehe einfach, wenn ich denke, was ist das für ein hausspannender Tür, gehe ich rein, ist die abgeschlossen, nein. Mensch, da kannst du nicht einfach so in Häuser rein gehen. Ich nehme die Welt wahr wie so ein Open-World-Spiel und manchmal sind halt spannende Perks versteckt zum Looten hinter der, in der offenen Türen. Gehe ich rein und dann stelle ich plötzlich in einem Wohnzimmer von einer Familie. Okay. Die war ein bisschen irritiert, aber erst am Ende. Und anstatt dich rauszuschmeissen hat er hat gesagt so. Die war beschäftigt mit ihrem Film, mit ihrem Experiment. Mit ihrem Experiment. Und dann hat die Frau den älteren Mann gefragt wieder, so jetzt zeig mal, wie du ein Foto machen würdest. Und er nahm, er hat dann diese typische
alte Kamera genommen, also diesen
wie als würdest du einen kleinen Rahmen.
Die zwei Greifkleppen. Genau, hat dann
auf den Auslöser gedrückt, oben der Finger
geschnellt herunter, nur um
dann wieder in die Höhe zu schnallen.
So, und dann wieder die
kleine Tochter gefragt, wie sie ein Foto machen
würde, und sie zeigt
das iPhone und ihren Zeigefinger, der auf dem Bildschirm, der Zeigefinger, der auf dem Bildschirm den Auslöser drückt. Genau, so würde sie ein Foto machen. Fand ich interessant, da passiert gerade eine Menge. Da passiert gerade wirklich eine Menge, ne? Naja, ich glaube einfach nur, dass es ein Handy ist, was viel ersetzt und so. Aber ich finde, du hast recht, es ist was anderes, es zu halten, als es darzustellen, damit die Flasche verhandeln müssen. Ich frage mich natürlich, wann ändert sich die Rechnung-Geste? Weil die Rechnung-Geste, also gibt es ja verschiedene Rechnungs-Gesten, aber es gibt einmal so die Hand, auf der die rechte Hand mit einem fiktiven Finger so unterschreibt, so Rechnung bitte, il conto per favore. So, und dann Daumen. Ja. Und dann gibt es, genau, dann gibt es den Check, die Checkrichtung, also will ich den kleinen Haken zu machen. Stimmt, ja, ja, stimmt. Aber das macht im Deutschen keinen Sinn, weil es ist ja der amerikanische Check. Ja. Wie würde man in Deutschland machen, wenn man die Rechnung haben will? Könnte ich bitte die Reichsbundesrechnung haben? Entschuldigung! Einmal die Bundesstaatsrechnung. Mit Bewertungsbeleg. Ja, schwierig im Deutschen, aber ich glaube, man versteht das, wenn man die goldene Mastercard in die Höhe streckt. Ja, gut, das stimmt das stimmt. Ja, aber auch da würde wahrscheinlich jetzt bald eine andere Geste kommen, wenn vielleicht eher die Karte, die man irgendwo heben stellt. Vielleicht so dieses Durchziehen durch das Lesegerät. Macht man ja auch nicht mehr. Interessant. Schon lange nicht mehr gemacht worden, Dean. Man zweibt nicht mehr durch Geräte. Das ist vielleicht mal eine nette Hausaufgabe für euch. Sucht, das würde mich interessieren, Handgesten, die man nicht mehr benutzt. Also sowas wie, also wir kennen ja noch den Fotoapparat in Alten, aber vielleicht irgendwas so aus, keine Ahnung, um 1900 herum, wo man so Handgesten, also ich meine so diese diese Fingerlaser, diese diese Pistolen, so die versteht man ja heute auch noch, weil die Pistole hat sich ja grundlegend kaum geändert. Dann haben wir einen Film gedreht und man zeigt sich noch dieses Drehdingen. Dieses Drehen des Films finde ich gut, ja. Das würde man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr machen. Doch, doch, der große Löffel und die Schüssel, so isst man immer noch Müsli. Aber was für Gesten wurden abgelöst und gibt es nicht mehr? Hupe, Hub, Hub. Interessant. Ohant, also falls ihr Gestenforscher seid.
Oh, was verschwindet ist, Auto anmachen, diese Schlüsselgeste, das ist jetzt oft einfach ein Drücken eines Start-Stopp-Knopf, Start-Stop.
Aber wann benutzt man diese Geste für, mein Auto springt nicht an?
Du musst ihn anmachen.
Wenn man, Frau, du musst ihn anmachen, statt So Autofahrer kommunizieren.
Ja, niemand, niemand.
Du hast recht, es ist keine Gesten, die man macht.
Aber das ist schon Blinken.
Die Blablabla-Geste, die du gerade machst.
Aber ist das nicht Blinken?
Ich mache so Blinken, wie die Sonne, weißt du?
Es wäre jetzt für euch, das nachzuvollziehen.
Mich nervt es, wenn Leute nicht blinken, und das mache ich immer so.
Aber es kann natürlich auch diese Blablabla-Geste sein. Hör auf, scheiße zu labern. Es ist eigentlich immer so, ich habe nichts gesagt. Nerviges Car-to-go-Auto fängt an, mich zu beleidigen. Aber das wäre auch geil. So ein gewisser Gesten-Analphabetismus, dass man immer so die falsche Geste macht, einfach so, und dann ist es auch so im Auto so, blablabla, blablablala. Was? Mach ich auch gut. Ah, das finde ich schön. Ja, aber das finde ich eine gute Hausaufgabe. Generell haben wir keine Hausaufgaben mehr aufgegeben. Sorry, Leute. Das Stöhnen geht durch den Raum, alle haben keinen Bock auf Hausaufgaben. Ja, muss sein, muss sein. Wir haben es nicht vergessen. Nee, wir haben es nicht vergessen. Wir haben es nicht vergessen. Wir werden es auch nicht vergessen. Nein. Also, gebt es bitte ab, pünktlich zur nächsten Folge. Und wir wollen auch keinen Namen mehr haben von Leuten, dessen Beruf es ist, wie sie heissen. Da kam sehr viel, überwältigend viel. Ich glaube, kein Aufruf hat jemals zu so vielen Nachrichten geführt. Was, glaube ich, einfach jetzt empirisch belegt ansagt, Menschen, die einen Namen haben, der zu irgendwas passt oder irgendwie einen Beruf suggeriert, wirklich
auch diesem Weg folgen.
Also ich glaube, wir können ja kurz Gewinner kühren,
von mir aus. Gewinner der
Name-wie-Beruf-Kategorie war
für mich der Tierarzt Herr Doktor Kuhmann.
Ja, den fand ich super.
Ich fand auch noch
Frau Hörauf gut, die Kindergärtnerin.
Das ist meine Gewinnerin. Frau Hör auf, Frau Hör auf, Kevin. Als Kindergärtnerin Frau Hör auf, wie so ein Pokémon, Hör auf, Hör auf, Hör auf, Hör auf. Ja, wo wir da bei Birds, Birds wären, für Vogelvideos, wo ein Hund die ganze Zeit mit dem Hund
redet und sagt, stop it,
stop it, und der Hund hört dann auf den
Vogel merkwürdiges Gefälle
an Größe und
ja, es stimmt schon, wer hat das
Sagen, so Alien Planet,
einfach kleines, weirdes
fliegendes, buntes Wesen redet
mit diesem Wolf und es ist
alles weird, alles ist komisch, everything is fucked, wir machen Fotos mit unseren Zeigefingern, alles ist anders, aber gut, Zeiten ändern sich. Ja, die Tierarchie ist eh komisch. Seid gewarnt, Zeiten ändern sich. Was meinst du damit? Nee, nur auf der Hut alle. Die Zeiten ändern sich, Session Ende. Du hast in Folge neun, vor sechs Jahren, hast du schon gesagt,
wir sollen auf der Hut sein.
Wir alle sind seit sechs Jahren konstant auf der Hut.
Ich glaube nicht, dass alle auf der Hut waren.
Kannst du ab einem gewissen Punkt auch mal eine Entwarnung geben?
Leute, ab jetzt nicht mehr auf der Hut.
Es gibt keine auf der Hut entwarnen.
Das ist nämlich immer das Problem, die Leute sagen,
Vorsicht, Vorsicht, Achtung, passt auf, pass auf dich auf,
pass auf dich auf.
Das muss auch irgendwann wieder mal beendet werden, aufgehoben werden.
Entspann dich, entspann dich.
So, jetzt hör auf, auf dich aufzupassen.
Jetzt hör auf, gesund zu bleiben.
Du musst nicht mehr auf der Hut sein.
Jetzt entspannt, jetzt ganz ruhig.
Jetzt ist einfach wieder, vielleicht müssen wir den Druck mal wieder runternehmen.
Ja, wobei, in den letzten Jahren kam schon viel entspann dich, meditier doch mal und so was.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen das Gegenteil von auf der Hut sein.
Naja, auch nicht wirklich, Achtsamkeit.
Man ist ja auch auf der Hut. Achtsam, auf der Hut sein heißt Naja, auch nicht wirklich. Achtsamkeit. Man ist ja auch auf der Hut.
Auf der Hut sein heißt ja nicht,
dass du immer on edge sein musst
und unentspannt sein musst.
Auf der Hut heißt einfach nur,
hört auf die Signale.
Ich habe eine neue Form
Zeitverschwendung gefunden.
Ich glaube, die dümmste Art der Zeitverschwendung
überhaupt, die man machen kann,
natürlich generell YouTube, man verbringt viel Zeit dort.
Aber ich glaube, die dümmste Art, die man sich angucken kann, ich habe sie gefunden und die verschlingt wahnsinnig viel Zeit und zwar angefangen hat es ja und das ist ja eine interessante Reise, die dieses Format genommen hat, das klassische Marble-Video, die Murmel. Und es gab lange Zeit einfach Murmelrennen, ja, Rennen, los, Gelbe, Gelbe, los. Und dann irgendwann ging das weiter in den digitalen Raum, in die sogenannte Digisphäre. Genau. Da gab es dann digitale Murmeln, die gegeneinander angetreten. Genau, hier gab es digitale Murmeln, aber es gab vorher noch natürlich, es sind alle einen Begriff, der Mann, ich glaube es ist ein Holländer, ein junger Mann, der die Olympia, die Marble Olympics immer durchführt. Genau, die Murmeln Olympiade, wo auch die Murmeln im Publikum saßen. Genau, das ist fantastisch. Was natürlich die Welt interessant macht, weil jetzt die Athleten halt, drehen die sich um sich herum oder sind das sozusagen Wesen, die nicht gerichtet sind? Nee, die Athleten, glaube ich, sind die rundesten Artgenossen. Meinst du? I don't know. Jedenfalls kämpfen die gegeneinander in Murmelwettbewerben. Und da bei der Klickanzahl, da hat man schon gesehen, oh, der Murmel, das ist da resonierend. Ja, das ist auch wichtig. So dieses Zugucken von Dingen, die so halb zufällig sind, und dann schauen wir, was passiert. Mittlerweile hat das viele, viele, viele Interessorten gegeben, und zwar
im digitalen Raum, und zwar gab es
irgendwann nicht mehr Murmelrennen,
sondern die Murmeln laufen irgendwo hin und lösen
dann was aus. Zum Beispiel, du hast
so vier Felder mit
Kanonen drin, und wenn die gelbe
Murmel irgendwo hinfällt,
dann wird ein Schuss ausgelöst.
Und dann gab es zum Beispiel, es gab
zwei Felder, wo die gelbe Murmel hinfallen könnte. Einmal auslösen, einmal multiplizieren. Und wenn du multipliziert hast, dann wurden deine Schüsse multipliziert. Hattest du zwei, vier, sechs, acht. Und wenn du dann ausgelöst hast, hat die Kanone achtmal geschossen. Und so kämpfen diese vier Farben gegeneinander. Und dieses Format hat sich so extrem weiter verkompliziert, dass es davon unendlich viele Videos gibt. Für welche Farbe bist du immer? Ich bin nur für grün. Okay. Aber gewinnt selten leider. Und diese Art von Videos sind unglaublich. Da gibt es im Internet wahnsinnig viele mit unglaublich ausgeklügelten Systemen, mit Buffs von Kanonen oder dann müssen Bäume wachsen oder irgendwelche Geschichten. Und es ist die absolute Zeitverschwendung, die absolute Zeitverschwendung. Aber ich bin gefangen, ich bin gefangen. Und ich hasse mich mit jeder Sekunde mehr, weil ich mir denke, das ist so dumm, das ist so dumm. Aber ich will am Ende doch wissen, wer gewinnt, weil der hat jetzt halt schon tausend Schüsse. Und wenn die jetzt ausgelöst werden, das ist ja so krass. Wäre es nicht so, so lustig, wenn dann so nach, genau, es wurde dann irgendwie eine Million mal gemacht von verschiedenen Leuten, gab es eine Million Durchgänge und es kommt raus, dass Blau ein fucking Loser ist. Stell dir vor, es kommt einfach raus, dass die Farbe Blau super inferior. Ja, wir haben das Programm tausendmal laufen lassen. Die Werte sind alle exakt gleich, aber Blau verliert immer. Blau verliert im Schnitt dreimal so häufig wie alle anderen Farben. Wohingegen Gelb gewinnt häufiger. Aber gut, das ist marginal und so, wir wissen nicht warum, aber Blau ist einfach ein scheiß Loser. Wir haben ab einem gewissen Punkt alles von dem Programm her gleich gelassen, wir haben nur die Farben getauscht. Die Mechaniken dahinter waren gleich. Stellt sich raus, wieder verliert Blau und wieder gewinnt Gelb überdurchschnittlich. Und dann Wissenschaftler zermatern sich den Kopf. Warum ist Blau so schwach? Blau ist die schwächste Farbe. So eine olle Loserfarbe. Alle hören auf, Blau zu tragen. Blau ist gleichach. Der Himmel wird verschmäht. Alle schauen den Himmel an und sagen, ha ha ha, weniger fliegen, mehr Bahn fahren, weil Himmel schwach. Der Himmel wird uncool. Meere, Meere wird uncool. Himmel wird uncool. Meere, Meeren wird wieder uncool. Uncool. Nach dem langen Hoch, jetzt wieder nach unten. Blaue Dinge werden uncool. Blaubeeren? Nicht mehr blau, blaue Augenfarbe, eher schwächere Menschen. Blaubeeren werden alle in den Rhein geworfen. Blaubeeren? Die ganzen Menschen versammeln sich, alle Kölner kommen zusammen. Kommen zusammen und mit Blaubeeren reinzuwerfen. Mit einem riesigen Container wird Blaubeeren in den Rhein gegossen. Aktuell ja wieder die Jecken sind unterwegs, ja Karl, meine Lieblingsjahreszeit, weil, haben wir schon oft gesprochen über das Phänomen, aber es ist jedes Jahr immer wieder geil, dieser Kontrast zwischen Kostüm und Verhalten. Da stehe ich dann zum Beispiel in der Kasse, relativ lange Schlange und dann hinter mir jemand, so können Sie jetzt mal nicht eine weitere Kasse aufmachen, drehe mich um und es ist ein 50-jähriger Mann, der das Gesicht so wie eine Maus geschminkt hat. Stocksauer? Rasen vom Wut. Stocksauer. Mensch, jetzt können wir mal eine neue Kasse aufmachen. Und dann siehst du dieses Mäuschen. Und er hat zwei Eierliköne in der Hand. Und ich denke mir so, Maus, wo musst du denn heute noch Wichtiges hin? Mausi. Warum hast du es denn eilig gerade?
Ist das Gesicht gerötet wegen Wut oder wegen Schminke?
Oder auch gestern saß ich im ICE und dann auch höre ich nur hinter mir so, Herr Scheiß-DB-Wider hier, Saftnaden.
Ich drehe mich nur so um, es sitzt jemand in so einer Jedi-Kutte da.
Ich dachte mir, ja dann tu was dagegen.
Du hast die Macht, etwas dagegen zu tun. Jedis meckern nicht, wenn die die B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B-B allein die Vorstellung, so ein Jedi-Ritter mit einem Rucksack, mit einem Jack-Wolfskin-Rucksack, die deutsche Bahn hier, der scheiß Saftladen hier. Das ist einfach immer fantastisch. Das ist einfach immer lustig. Man hat so das Gefühl, man steigt in das Privatleben von diesen Figuren ein so ein bisschen. Obi-Wan Kenobi, wenn er gerade nicht die Welt rettet, dann nervt das ja scheiß Wiederverspätung hier. Das Schöne an Karneval in Köln ist ja auch, dass Leute so häufig Kostüme tragen und auch so lange, dass sie vergessen, dass sie das Kostüm anhaben. Und dann man mit dieser Clash... Diese Gesichtsschminke, das vergisst du ja sofort. Also wenn es jetzt nicht irgendwie dich behindert oder so, dann vergisst du sofort, dass du ein kleines Mäuschen bist. Ja, dann ruft man Bild umher. Sehr gut, das finde ich fantastisch. Allein die Vorstellung, dass du am Abend nach Hause kommst und in den Spiegel schaustust und denkst oh fuck, ich hatte die ganze Zeit
die Maus, ich hab versucht eine Schlägerei anzufangen
ich hab Schluss gemacht
mit meiner Partnerin, ich hab eine Schlägerei angefangen
ich hab nur einen Ausweis beantragt
ich hab Fotos für den Ausweis
gemacht
oh ich vollidiot
dann hab ich die schwangere Mitarbeiterin
gekündigt. Oh nein! Oh, wie furchtbar. Ah, shit. Ah, scheiße. Ah, das war unangenehm. Ja, das war, hätte ich vielleicht auch einen anderen Zeitpunkt wählen sollen. Ja, da beißt die keinen Faden ab. Da kommen wir mit dem Budget leider nicht mehr hin. Ist das ein Scherz? Nein, nein, überhaupt nicht. Also die wirtschaftliche Lage spitzt sich zu. Und ja, dieses ewige Katz-und-Maus-Spiel können wir so nicht weiterführen. Deswegen müssen wir sie entlassen. Was? Sie wollen mich kündigen?
Ja, nein, es sind so wenige Aufträge in die Falle gekommen in der letzten Zeit.
Sie dürfen Schwangere gar nicht kündigen.
Ich habe so Hunger. Sorry.
Kann es sein, dass sie gar nicht schwanger sind, sondern dass sie Hunger sind?
Also sie einfach hungrig sind? Sorry, ich habe auch so Hunger.
Jetzt war das Baby, was so ruft. Was soll das für eine Scheiße sein? Was sagt der Typ in dem Mauskostüm gerade? Mama, was soll doch von dem Arsch im Mauskostüm nichts sagen, du? Ich hab zu Hunger. Er ist etwas frühreif. Wir machen halt so lange Knurren. Ich hab nichts in Laugenbrötchen. Wir werden gehäckelt von meinem Magen. Nee, du hast mir nicht dein Maugenbrötchen geben. Ehrlich jetzt? Willst du mir dein Laugenbrötchen geben? Das ist ein ganzes Laugenbrötchen. Aber willst du es selber nicht haben? Guck hier. Dankeschön. Warum willst du es selber nicht haben? Nein, nein, ich habe noch ein Brötchen. Ist da ein Finger drin von dir? Sag ehrlich, ist da ein Finger von dir drin? Beiß rein und sag du es mir. Du hast nämlich nur noch drei Finger, wo sind die alle? Ich wünsche euch eine fantastische Woche, kommt gut durch diese Woche, habt Spaß, schickt uns Gesten, die es nicht mehr gibt. Schickt uns auch gerne Videos von euch, damit ihr nicht so unangenehm die Geste beschreiben müsst, so Kopfnicken, zur Seite wendend, sondern schickt uns gerne einfach ein Video und dann viel Spaß damit. Haut rein, wünsche euch eine schöne Woche. Bis die Tage, sag ich mal, man sieht sich.
Bis die Tage, man sieht sich, haut rein, wir heben ab.
Ciao!